Speaker 1: Since Republicans have taken over
control of the House of Representatives,
they have held a bunch of these
different hearings that are, of course,
hearings meant only to virtue signal and meant
only to not focus on issues actually facing the
country. This includes hearings about big tech
or the weaponization of the FBI. And yesterday,
there was one such hearing in which they brought
out the attorney general, Merrick Garland,
to answer questions. Ted Cruz went to law school,
and yet he seemed completely confused about how
the law works. In this first clip and these
hearings really went wrong so quickly. And
we'll talk about what these are really meant
to accomplish in a moment. In this first clip,
Ted Cruz starts talking about leaks. And Merrick
Garland has to explain to him. Remember, Cruz is
a lawyer. No, no, no, no, no. That wasn't a leak.
That was a court filing. Those are, by definition,
made public. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: As you know, the FBI raided
Donald Trump's Mar a Lago home. And subsequent to
that raid, there have been multiple leaks about
what was discovered there, including a photograph
of documents that were discovered there.
Did did you know about the leaks? The phone in.
Speaker 3: The photograph was a filing in court
in response to a motion filed
by Mr. Trump. It was not a leak.
Speaker 2: So you're testifying there
haven't been leaks about the Trump raid.
Speaker 3: And I'm responding
to the point at yeah.
Speaker 1: Ted Cruz is a lawyer. Doesn't he know
how the law works? He went to law school. Well,
it doesn't matter because Ted Cruz is there,
not as someone with some legal knowledge,
as as rudimentary as it might be. He's there as a
performer who is there to attack Merrick Garland
and to further a narrative that everything that
has gone on with the investigation into Donald
Trump has been some kind of politically biased
subterfuge or plan or whatever the case may be.
Then the subject comes up of protesters outside
the homes of Supreme Court justices. And again,
I'm guessing Ted Cruz knows this stuff, but Ted
Cruz wants to pretend that it is up to Merrick
Garland to enforce statutes, but it is actually up
to law enforcement on the scene. And it is another
one of these just deranged performative moments
that Ted Cruz thinks make him look really good.
Speaker 2: How do you decide
which criminal statutes the
DOJ enforces and which one it doesn't?
Speaker 3: The United States Marshals
know that they have full.
Speaker 2: I recognize you
want to give a separate speech.
Speaker 3: Oh, I don't want.
Speaker 2: How do you decide which statute
you enforce and which ones you don't.
Speaker 3: But marshals on scene
make that determination in light
of the priority of the marshals.
Speaker 2: Do not make a determination
over whether to prosecute you, the attorney
general, make a determination. And you spent 20
years as a judge and you're perfectly content with
justices being afraid for their children's lives.
Speaker 1: And you this is understand, this is
merely a performance. This is not to investigate
or learn a damn thing.
Speaker 2: It's nothing
to prosecute it. Let's do it.
Speaker 3: Can I answer the question?
Speaker 2: No. The judge refused to answer.
Speaker 3: I am answering.
Speaker 1: Your. I'm. You're not.
I'm here to perform, Mr. Attorney
General. Not for you to answer my questions.
Speaker 3: Question. The attorney General
does not decide whether to ask.
Speaker 2: How did you choose
not not to enforce this statute?
Speaker 3: The marshals I'm sorry.
Speaker 2: Don't make that decision.
Speaker 3: Do make the decision of whether
to make them rescue someone.
Speaker 2: No, they don't.
Speaker 3: If they make
them if they make marshals.
Speaker 2: Do not have prosecute.
Speaker 3: If they make
an arrest and not go to the.
Speaker 2: Tropics, because our our
time is limited.
Speaker 1: The time is limited because
Ted Cruz won't actually let the witness answer the
questions. And of course, Ted Cruz is blending two
different things. Ted Cruz is blending what
actions were and weren't taken at the homes
of Supreme Court justices, which is completely up
to law enforcement. And then as a separate matter,
once Merrick Garland, to discuss indictments,
which are a separate issue to actions taken or not
taken at the homes of law enforcement. And again,
I know Ted Cruz is like sort of dim, but he's not
this dim. And we all know Ted Cruz knows that. Ted
Cruz then continues in turning. He's determined
to turn this hearing into a farce, which he very
easily did. And he starts talking about what is
effectively a conspiracy theory for which there is
no evidence arguing that the Department of Justice
leaked about investigating Hunter Biden to serve
as a pretext to indict Trump by being able to say,
See, we're nonpartisan. If that's confusing
to you, if that doesn't make sense to you,
it's because it doesn't make sense.
Speaker 2: Toward that end,
the Department of Justice has leaked that DOJ is
investigating. And intends to indict Hunter Biden.
The purpose of those leaks, I believe, was to
set the predicate for an indictment of Trump
to say, look how evenhanded we are. We're
indicting a Biden, we're indicting a Trump.
Those leaks are not law speculation.
Speaker 1: Conspiracy theory, unfounded,
no evidence and also not a question to the witness
that is there. But remember, these hearings in
some total are performances. That's what they are
meant to be. That's what they are meant to be.
Another interesting moment was in this exchange
with Ted Cruz. Merrick Garland points out,
you know, some of you Republican senators
are arguing that we like to help the left.
Now, you're saying the leaks are to help the
right. It's all incoherent, but good for Merrick
Garland for pointing it out.
Speaker 3: The answer is the.
Speaker 2: Leaks are consistently
on one side of the aisle,
advancing one political agenda.
Speaker 4: So. It doesn't seem to me,
Attorney General, that the FBI has a lot of
confidence in you, because what they're doing
clearly is trying to distance themselves from your
decisions. They're out there leaking left, right
and center and saying it wasn't us. We didn't
want to do it. He made us do it right. What does
that say about their confidence in your leaders?
Speaker 1: So understand here and Garland will
address it. Cruz is arguing you're making
all these leaks to help the left. And Josh
Hawley is saying the leaks are coming
out actually from people who don't agree
with you in order to help the right job.
Speaker 3: No, the previous senator said
that they are leaking all in favor of the left.
Now you're saying they're leaking all in favor?
Speaker 4: I'm asking you my question. Answer
my question. Based on this evidence, don't
dissemble Attorney general's answer my question.
Speaker 3: Time has expired, Senator Cotton.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So Merrick Garland
accurately figuring out what the story
is here. And it's a story that makes
absolutely no no sense whatsoever.
Here is Merrick Garland, then, debunking the
Republican talking point about the FBI being
used on parents. Remember, this was floating
around for a while. Oh, they're sending the FBI,
their delegate. They're declaring parents to be
domestic terrorists if they go to school board
meetings. And the FBI is getting involved. This
was during questioning from Senator John Kennedy.
Speaker 5: Didn't you understand?
Speaker 1:
By the way, isn't isn't John Kennedy insufferable?
Speaker 5: The chilling effect that it would have?
Two parents. When you issued your directive,
when you directing your criminal divisions
and your counter terrorism divisions
to to investigate parents who are angry at
school boards and administrators during COVID.
Speaker 3: Center, If you just give me a moment
to put the full context. I did not do that.
I did not issue any memorandum directing the
investigation of parents who are concerned
about their children. Quite to the contrary, the
memorandum that you're talking about says at the
very beginning of the memorandum that vigorous
public debate is protected by the First Amendment.
And the kind of concerns that you're talking
about are, as expressed by parents are, of course,
completely protected. The memorandum was aimed at
violence and threats of violence against a whole
host of school personnel. It was not aimed at
parents making complaints to their school board.
And it came in the context of a whole series of
other kinds of violence, threats and violence
against other public officials.
Speaker 1: Yeah, they don't care.
They're just getting the question on the
record. You have to understand, you know,
Merrick Garland is doing the best he can, but
all of these questions are just performances.
And these are sort of like auditions for who's
going to get on HANNITY later on last night.
Another interesting moment. Senator Marsha
Blackburn told Merrick Garland she's going
to send him a bunch of Twitter.
Speaker 6: You told me
earlier that you didn't know who James Revenge is.
They are all over Twitter. I'm going to do you a
favor. I am going to send you a letter with
a whole lot of Twitter and different feeds
to help you and that.
Speaker 1: She's
going to help him by sending him feeds.
Speaker 6: Investigation for the Hope Clinic.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Marsha Blackburn will help the
Department of Justice by sending Merrick Garland
a whole bunch of Twitter. Once a viewer sent
me a whole bunch of AltaVista, I barely knew
what to do with it. It was really crazy. And then
lastly, here is Republican Senator from Arkansas,
Tom Cotton, asking Merrick Garland, Why did the
DOJ not arrest protesters outside the homes of
Supreme Court justices? Listen to how that went.
Speaker 7: Consider the effort your department
has put into tracking down everyone who is
even on the Capitol grounds on January six,
2021. You've dedicated millions of man.
Speaker 1: Hours, millions to.
Speaker 7: Study videotape, to do forensic
analysis of computers and devices, to go knock and
conduct interviews. You can't allocate just a few
agents to look at people's social media account
to say they were president outside of a justice
home. We're going to go arrest them and charge
them. It's a black letter violation of the law.
Speaker 3: Our priority is violence and threats
of violence and but protection of the lives
of the justices. And that is what we're doing.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Why did you spend all this
time? Trying to figure out who all of the
criminals were on January 6th. And yet you're not
out there trying to figure out who stood holding
a sign outside of a Supreme Court justices
house. Why isn't that evidence of bias? Well,
we're focused on violence and threats of violence.
So that's that's why we did things the way we did
them. So, listen, this probably accomplished
its goals in so far as it was meant to be a
performative display of repeating the half and
dimwitted concerns of the Fox News audience,
quite frankly, who only has these concerns because
the very same people on these panels told them,
Here's what you need to be concerned about. And so
it probably accomplish that goal. Merrick Garland
did absolutely fine, but every single one of these
hearings, just a complete and total face plant,
and they're not going to stop because they're
then going to use these hearings to justify.
We did things. We accomplished things even
though these hearings accomplish nothing.